[Musik]
willkommen zum dritten teil von reporter
spezial mit beschäftigen wir uns mit dem
leben im alter was machen müssen
senioren ist eine idee die gemeinschaft
exportieren zum beispiel nach ungarn
tätig modell kids oder sind sie böse der
schweiz besser auf gruppen zum beispiel
seiner institutionen wie m fliegt sein
comeback die isla kam vor gut einem jahr
nach einem sturz direkt vom spital ins
pflegezentrum wache und war am anfang
todunglücklich
von einem moment auf den anderen war er
selbst bestimmtes leben zu ende
doch halte isla hat sich aufgerappelt in
einem einzelzimmer und mit ihrem elektro
scooter lebt sie ein kleines stück
selbständigkeit weiter im auge bleibt
immer im pflegeheim und wenigsten
vorschläge sind schön aber wenn ich sie
alle hass für keinen gut leben
es braucht überwinden sondern der wahl
gewesen reporter verlor standort und wer
akzeptiert dann der bis kurz wachstums
erhalten oder ist eine großartige rolle
sie müsse dringend tätig unter der so
oder de hat omega lotto jackpot im lotto
spielen oder da kann ich nur einige
frauen aussagen zu den werden kuchen
die frau habe mich nach klärt
lottospieler kindern zwar zum größten
dass er tore haben zwei galaxien mit
innerer google auch unsere privat
schauen und habe das ohne vater geboren
wir haben ja
ja ich bin halb heidi isla treffen wir
später in dieser sendung wieder ihr
neues zuhause das pflegezentrum bachler
bietet 90 plätze hier werden alte
menschen langfristig gepflegt aber auch
temporäre bewohner aufgenommen
zudem stehen plätze im bereich
palliativpflege zur verfügung
zusammen mit den standorten embrach und
nürensdorf bildet das bach lehn
wasserstoff das kompetenzzentrum pflege
und gesundheit kurz kz visa wie vor mir
sitzt marlies patrick sie ist das cabrio
in bächli der schritt für die haie ins
pflegezentrum wie viele tonnen machen
der schritt wirklich plant und wie viele
eigentlich nur wenn es anders kommt als
man es nicht anders gut sieben bis acht
prozent symmetrie mit nach einem
spitalaufenthalt wohin dieser kurs
passierte lungenentzündung es brauche
und dass die team-trophy wirklich dass
wir das eben nicht plant hat mit gott
nicht eines plug zentrums hat neben
ihrem beruf triebes innere logik sondern
sich so kurz ereignis und das führt
liter hier erleben zum beispiel
glückliche menschen oder einfach so
wenig wo resignierten alles sehr
glücklich ließ florian os entdeckt wo
neue freundschaften schließen
es ist aber auch moment kultur möglich
ist sache wo man verabschiedet hier wie
andere bewohner innen verlegt wie sie
sterben als sich die ganze bandbreite
wieso shiml aber es geht jetzt im moment
andere konzepte oder demnach erleben so
im letzten lebensabschnitt und eines
davon ist heim im ausland zum beispiel
in ungarn
wenn sie das gehört
was macht das mit ihnen aber auch dank
ritze ich glaube mir oft was die
menschen stellt was sie braucht für
hilfe und was man für personal muss eine
stelle um ihr redet wenig darüber was
die manche gesellschaft immer noch für
bekannt was ja für den richtung bringen
was ich für das geschickt hat was sie
als jüngere lehrern wo sie als 3
erinnert und das wirklich nicht
exportieren
das gericht will ich wieder in der
schweiz es gibt die möglichkeit die alt
sein
in ungarn ist mein bruder simon christen
ist ein glatter sieg reist und hat
startet alltag für seniorinnen und
senioren
ein kleines dorf gute zwei autostunden
entfernt von budapest die altersresidenz
senior palace 2014 eröffnet sieht man
von weitem neubauten inmitten einer
kargen landschaft
es gibt eine alters- und pflegeheim mit
50 plätzen und eine kleine
bungalowsiedlung eine art
alterswohnungen stehen zwölf plätze zur
verfügung die seine jahr sollen es 24
sein
[Musik]
das ehepaar brand hat sich vor einem
jahr hier eingemietet
wenn sie wollen können sie in ihrem
bungalow essen
sie können aber auch runter ins
altersheim wo es frühstück mittag und
abendessen gibt ganz nach belieben
walter brand ist nach einem hirnschlag
und diversen politischen anfällen
angeschlagen seine frau trudy noch fit
das geheimnis ob sich nur durch meine
hose und einfach alles viel größer
und jetzt hat man sich bei freenet im
alter und das ist gut so und durch
gewalt sehr gut dass die wohnform ist
also einmalig sie können kommen und
gehen wie sie wollen und wenn sie hilfe
brauchen können sie rund um die uhr auf
einen notfall knopf drücken und in
minuten ist das personal vor ort so gut
verhält die sonden land vor allem der
oper etappen gelobe und aber runde mit
dem personal des super gut also wirklich
enttäuscht und aufmerksam aus so dass in
demmin sich nur positiv es ist nur
positiv und auch der preis stimmt die
brandstellen gut 2000 franken pro monat
für ihren bungalow mit stampfli ist vor
zwei jahren von der stadt bayern an den
plattensee gezogen
sie ist ein mit offenen armen empfangen
worden sagt sie und habe sich sofort zu
hause gefühlt hatte sich eine frische
liter schweiz ins altersheim zu vier
händen seiner vorstellung
aber der muss halt zeigen ich habe nein
gesagt
tor nummer vorteile
[Musik]
blut stampfli hat ein wohn einschlaf und
ein badezimmer die meiste zeit verbringt
sie in ihren vier wänden denn das gehen
fällt ihr schwer
sie benötigt inzwischen intensive pflege
[Musik]
die zange gehabt gestrige den
abrechnungen büro im 2004 ist für 40 pro
monat im monat das ist es das ist märz
und im februar ist völlig unter frank
kramer oder 100 franken weniger es so
einfach hat wirklich rosig
und was ist alles inbegriffen und
transport ist schauspielerin oder arzt
und damit woche gut das ist mit die
kommen dass ich dennoch das konnte schon
separat aber das geht
das tote tier denke der schweiz hat die
komplette mindestens
[Musik]
der unternehmer albert er hat
geschäftlichen umgang zu tun und macht
einen zwischenhalt am plattensee
es ist bereits sein zweiter augenschein
in der altersresidenz senior palace nach
seinem ersten besuch waren so
beeindruckt dass er seine baut 100
jährige tante umgehend hierher bringen
wollte wo sie recht hat wird sie
reagiert mit interesse vielleicht aber
spitzte ungläubiger machen will ungarn
ich natürlich nicht wie der dax
obwohl eigentlich hitze dax mit der
flugzeuge schon mal in anderthalb
stunden budapest und die stand sie sagen
so hoch wie sich das der autor ist wird
auch in das vorstellt bayer ist der
einzige verwandte den seine konnte noch
hat sie hatte ihm eine generalvollmacht
ausgestellt und ihn als bevollmächtigten
in ihrer patientenverfügung genannt also
entschied er in absprache mit ihr dass
sie ihre letzten jahre in ungarn
verbringen wird sich nicht am kyoto
wieso denn es ist schon untersagt wurde
oder dass ich mir untersagt wurde
dante fuß im alter sein wo sie jetzt in
der schweiz nach ungarn zu verbringen
gefunden kann das eeg unakzeptabel
ich mache ich das richtig dass
finanzielle gründe um kosten von
altersheims sparen was natürlich
überhaupt zutrifft sich sicher ein
aspekt aber mir geht es lediglich um
laue qualität vom intelligenten und
einfach finden und das hat sich jetzt
wieder bestätigen
das ist ja einfach heuchlerisch mit dem
alter sein als sie damit der schweiz
schweizerische ist für mich ob es
zwischen klinik und inneren anstalt es
ist zwar alles organisiert es ist alles
da großfeld wären
es fällt persönlichkeit wer versuchte
gegen den entscheid der kest vorzugehen
erfolglos er hat nichts mehr zu sagen
ein beistand entscheidet das
vormittagsprogramm ein ungarisch kurs
der senior palace wurde für finanz
starke ausländer konzipiert die bewohner
kommen aus deutschland österreich und
der schweiz
die meisten ungarn können sich so ein
angebot nicht leisten
ich bin überzeugt sie wird sich da wofür
du willst es ist einmalig die dritte
band silly und und nach sei das wäre
jetzt ein streichelzoo werde ich danach
mache mit dir wird vorne gemacht und
jetzt einig sei und da bin ich einfach
hundertprozentig hat das mandant wird
sich da wohl ganz
in ungarn herrscht eigentlich hab mutter
mangel an ärzten und pflegepersonal für
die einheimischen gibt es in den
staatlichen alters und pflegeheimen
lange wartelisten
eine pflegerin verdient dort weniger als
500 euro pro monat im senior palace sind
die löhne deutlich besser darum waren
dann nicht auch kräftig ihre ab oder ins
ausland
[Musik]
der lebensabend in ungarn hat auch für
die brawns schattenseiten
sie sind zum beispiel weit weg von ihren
kindern und ein kann ist das für sie
wenn sie das goethe zu verdanken dass
ich ruhig sind dass sie weit weg sind
ist das für sie als eher schlicht
einfacher suchen
ich weiß nicht andere es ist aber damit
auf die idee ihre 20
wie schön ja ich habe ganz kurz groß ich
bin ja schon eine extreme vermied er ja
ja ja
wer will ein guter mensch sein und das
tun was seiner meinung nach das beste
für seine tempi wäre aber er lief ins
leere erzählte frank dem geschäftsführer
des senior palace ich habe den falschen
hand offeriert hierherzukommen sich
selber ein bild zu verschaffen
und ich habe gesagt also wenn das für
ihn keinen interessenkonflikt wäre würde
ich ihm das gerne bezahlen die reise das
ist überhaupt darf kein interesse
gestoßen
und da habe ich natürlich ein problem
mit einer solchen haltung oder wenn man
nicht ein etwas kritisiert ohne es zu
kennen und nicht bereit ist sich
überhaupt ein bild geben zu lassen oder
sie selber ein bild zu machen von einer
situation dann finde ich das eine völlig
inakzeptabel
sogenannte gymnastikraum oder
rehabilitation zu hauen
sie haben wir einen nürnberger käfig
auch durch frank gebürtige deutsche hat
eine marktlücke entdeckt seine firma
senior palace hat inzwischen filialen in
mehreren ehemaligen ostblockstaaten ein
wachstumsmarkt ist er sich sicher
auch hier ist nicht alles friede freude
eierkuchen
das ehepaar auf dem weg zum mittagessen
das die beiden in ungarn im auto seien
gelandet sind ist kein zufall
sie hatten hier seit langem ein
ferienhaus irgendwann ließen sie sich
frühpensionieren und wanderte nach
ungarn aus
und als trudi brand ihren mann nicht
mehr allein betreuen konnte sind sie
geblieben
sie mögen die ungarische lebensfreude
das klima und auch das essen
ihre tischnachbarn beide deutsche sind
skeptischer oft sei es fad es fehle die
schärfe funktioniert obwohl die
verständigung funktioniert so sauber
dass wir effizient montag den
unterschied nicht alles bestimmen
[Musik]
blut fließt im moment zu schwach für den
weg in den speisesaal
sie ist in ihrem zimmer
wieso das muss ich muss ich passen
jeder sollte sich ernsthaft überlegen
seinen lebensabend im ausland zu
verbringen meint albert da ist eine
osterglocke so lasse sich verhindern
dass im alter das ganze vermögen
aufgebraucht werde in der hand aber
gesellschaftliche dimension da wo
mittelfeld vernachlässigen die früher
eine hantel dritte junge hat eine
starthilfe für ihre zukunft jede
berufliche um da ich gebe mir dass ich
das unfair dass effektiv die jungen und
die alten unterstütze in der direktor
der indirekt und das geld fehlt nach er
die junge mann stark ist lebensraum das
rutscht amtliche landete hat damit zu
tun dass ihre tochter in ungarn lebt und
ihre mutter so zusammen mit riesigen
fronten regelmäßig besuchen kann
die hektik
wir sind wieder zurück da vielleicht so
ein trumm bächli und bei mir ist albert
baier nein sie habe vorher keine klärung
dieser reportage und auch bei mir sind
vreni und der walfisch muss man sich
schon sehr gemäßigt verwandt miteinander
reiner zufall
vreni fitch bleibt anders radio da
impfzentren der paraplegiker habe nur
schwere lungenentzündung und so sind sie
eigentlich da ist eine mitteilung der
firma chlorgehalt dass sein team in
ungarn könnte sich das vorstellen
das leben einer familie nach der doppik
also da kann man sich vorstellen meint
sie das überhaupt gewusst dass es zig
alters sein trägt das geht in ungarn es
gibt aber zum beispiel in thailand
gehört das gebiet und meine kleine
tricks aber denn weil es keine rolle
dass die wiederum setzt man sowieso
stimmt in ungarn als ökonomisch werden
darf dass sie dem thema rolle spiele
also dorfes rolle spiele wie viel das
kostet im alter muss rollen spielen ist
eine durch muss er mit sich selber
abmachen
weil manches kind hat beispielsweise
oder und sich dann überlegen wir jetzt
glauben sie vermögen aufbrauchen im
altersheim oder war mir nach umgang und
das kind am schlossen heute behindert
das war ja so eine konfliktsituation im
grund genommen
aber das muss familie mit der familie
ausmachen
muss man sich da für gesellschaften mir
ali also außer meinen also aber die
idealen sich die einfach für sich oder
und andere militante gefühle das aber
küssen gesellschaftliche pflicht ich
kann das geld es ist das für sie ist
thema diskutiert mit auch mit genannt ja
das gibt der classics liveticker das ist
[Musik]
nicht einfach und das einfach so
akzeptieren dass man nebenbei defender
immer geschafft hat und ja noch einen
muss man sie aber auf granit aus dass
noch bis über kommt also da verletzt
einen das stolz
man merkt das land eigentlich immer in
dem moment plötzlich konzipiert die
macht so schnell also das wort cool dass
ich alles versuche alles getan hat und
der stand ist das für sie also
irgendwann ist der moment wo sie sich
ein bisschen entscheiden muss prämie ist
alzheimer 30 casino die haie ohne
blieben einzig dem moment auch
extra-züge denn das ist
und wenn jetzt einfach gott nehme die
haie temporär insgeheim entsorger bis 1
wieder gott und den jetzt einfach
kreises ordnet sie ist also für
wirkliches wie wir auch gesundheitlich
angeschlagen und dann ist es schon
schwierig zum sagte tiere war ja von
ihnen beider ist der schritt schwierig
sie die musik für die justiz
das wahrscheinlich gar nicht nutzen weil
ich bin sagt petry und ich glaube nicht
dass ich da mit der user kommen also
hört sich so an station und zum glück
kunden
wir könnten am nachmittag tochter und
vier
also das ist sehr angenehm und ich hab
was wünschen sie sich vielleicht auf der
von der gesellschaft für menschen wie
sie wo immer prägt ein traum bleiben
also dass sie respektiert wird es zu
wenig binden unnötigen wie aus dass sie
noch ein danken und sie mit entscheiden
eines kindes oder nicht entscheiden
aber ich hoffe dass fliegt euro mehr sie
viermal
das sind alles gute und wie der
pflegealltag ausgesät dadurch selber
welches bild davon machen ist reporterin
helen armee ist mit der kamera dpx und
heute an sogar schönes wetter
[Musik]
der arbeitsort von heiko schulz ist kein
normales pflegeheim sondern eine
geschlossene demenzabteilung im
pflegezentrum embrach drama kreiert sie
ja frau meier ich du nochmal zu decken
die beine einfach dass sie sich nicht
erschrecken so bis sperrte frau meier
das dritte mal
aber auch das dritte mal dass sie
angefangen zu lächeln und das ist genau
das warum ich das eigentlich auch mache
weil ich weiß mit zwei minuten
investition fühlt sie sich sicher
fröhlich und denkt dass uns so das nennt
man bei uns so diese ritualisierten
begegnung und damit kann man sehr sehr
viel sicherheit vermitteln so ergibt
sich erhoffte können sie da auch sehr
häufig du schnell baute raus ich komme
gleich demenzkranke menschen leben in
einer eigenen welt
die arbeit mit ihnen ist ein ständiges
erahnen von bedürfnissen und der führen
von grenzen
man kann es bei den menschen merken die
jetzt in der demenz noch nicht ganz
soweit sind da merkt man oft auch dass
sie sich schämen oder das schamgefühl
sehr stark ausgeprägt ist und das ist
ein sehr sensibles thema wo man wirklich
auch sehr behutsam mit umgehen muss und
auch sich wie art wir so langsam
rantasten wann es wirklich hilfe auch
gewollt
wo worte ihren zweck verfehlen wird
einfühlungsvermögen umso wichtigere am
meisten belasten kann sich der andere
sieht können sie da zum bett laufe ja
ich weiß nicht
wollen sie es probieren wollen sich denn
mal alle sieht ja bezieht kann sich da
gerade sitzen ja nur langsam
genau das ist das für das grab für das
kloster das benutzen wir eigentlich
hauptsächlich für bewohner die nicht
mehr alleine stehen können hier aber in
der speziellen situation ich jetzt
vorbereitet benutzen wir das auch ein
bisschen die sicherheit zu gewährleisten
haben bewohner der öfters auch aggressiv
reagiert und da ich genau das problem
dass er zum beispiel einen moment das
gleichgewicht verliert und mit stark an
wie in hefe wollen aber er in dem moment
wenn duell uns dann den arm beißt oder
uns boxt gott ja fast ein bisschen kopf
offen und deswegen benutzen wir das in
dieser situation um für ihn und für uns
die sicherheit zu gewährleisten
nachricht im pflegezentrum ein notruf
aus einer anderen abteilung wieder um
geld
wir versuchen gleich zu helfen machen
uns erst mal bisschen platz
und dann kommt so ein bisschen raum
musik und sieht uns als bedrohung an
versuchen sie mal auf sie zu der weg ins
pflegeheim ist eine einbahnstraße happy
ends sind für außenstehende nur schwer
vorstellbar
happy ends sind für mich zum beispiel
wenn jemand im sterben liegt und er hat
keine schmerzen er wird gut betreut die
angehörigen werden gut betreut man
schaut und macht was man kann das ist
für mich auch ein happy end und das
vielleicht auch ein happy end vom labour
oder wenn man wie gesagt ohne schmerzen
gehen kann und mit der einbahnstraße ist
halt immer so eine sache ich finde auch
auf der letzten fahrt sollte man
wirklich auch gut betreut werden und man
freut sich immer über einen freundlichen
schaffen wirklich personifizierte geduld
sie aber eine fernsehkamera die hand
aufs herz könnte das defizit für ihre
patienten ja ich glaube das geht nicht
nur mir so es ist denke ich oft meinen
kollegen dass es wirklich ja doch nicht
immer so ist wie im film
wir versuchen natürlich immer da zu sein
für unsere bewohner und es ist auch ganz
wichtig weil sie merken auch wenn wir
keine zeit haben das heißt sie sind
seien gar nicht zufrieden oder sie
brauchen dann auch noch mehr zeit weil
sie das leben spüren und
ja wir versuchen das was wir machen
können es ist nicht jeden tag gleich
wird es für viele die vorstellung dass
sie irgendwann im und im entwertet und
auf seiner station sind wie sie es nennt
sich für jede homo ehe selbst nicht nur
mitglied wurde meint sind ja gut ich bin
furchtbar
also wenn wir selber uns die frage
stellen menschen mit demenz werden
glaube ich wird keiner sagen ja das ist
alles ganz gut und das wird dann schon
irgendwie ja ich denke es gibt so
bestimmte phasen auch hunderte menz und
ich glaube ganz am anfang wo man das
selber sehr realisiert ist es extrem
schwierig für die menschen und auch mit
sehr viel verlust hat zu tun mit sehr
viel angst und ich denke nachher wenn
die menschen doch ihre fähigkeiten noch
mehr verloren haben uns vielleicht
selber gar nicht mehr so realisieren
dann fängt es extrem aber auch schwierig
an für die angehörigen zu werden und
dass es dann so wir manchmal so
situationen erleben dass der der mensch
mit seiner demenz vielleicht doch ganz
glücklich ist aber die angriffe sind
sehr sehr traurig weil sie den bezug
verlieren und weil sie immer mehr mühe
haben im zugang zu finden so den
menschen denen sie doch so lange schon
kannten und er sich dann doch verändert
klingt sie nur traurig große dosis
kühlein dass ich jetzt noch die letzte
meile
ja ich empfinde es gar nicht so wie die
vorstellung so geprägt ist das gar
nichts läuft dass die leute einfach nur
sitzen und gar nicht mehr miteinander
reden
ich habe er das gefühl es passieren auch
ganz ganz spannende sache auf einer
demenzabteilung ganz viel witzige sachen
auch auch die leute lachen viel
das ist realität und man kann auch
gemeinsam lachen miteinander lachen und
das sind dann die schönen momente wo ja
wo man auch merkt dass man den menschen
und dem moment dann doch etwas gegeben
hat und so lächelt sowie
ja das beste ergebnis was machen können
wir wissen wir werden immer älter
pflegenotstand das ist nicht nur das ist
zum teil schon realität die länge ziehen
so unsere zukunft genauso wenn wir beide
irgendeine moneyplex wer das sind dass
blackwater wo wir denn dahin ja ich
denke wir werden das sehr schwierig
haben mit pflegeroboter weil es einfach
nicht gewohnt sind und das
wahrscheinlich auch nicht zu unserer
kultur gehört das könnte sicherlich eine
lösung sein für andere kulturen das gibt
es schon aber ich denke das sollte nicht
die entwicklung sein
ich denke wir müssen mit hilfsmitteln
schaffen auch mit technologien die uns
helfen aber die menschen wird es immer
brauchen und vom pflegenotstand ich
denke jetzt spielt man es immer mehr
einfach dass sie wirklich die
pflegefachleute ja schwieriger zu
rekrutieren sind dass es auch gerade von
langzeit bereich ist es ist mühsam viele
wollen im spital und spittal wird alles
immer so schön dargestellt und ja der
langzeit bereich muss kämpfen dass sie
gute leute kommen und das ist eben
darauf sollte sich der aufruf oder das
passieren ganz spannende sache und sind
das ist ein ganz komplexe situation auch
im langzeit bereich und dafür braucht
extrem gute leute dankbar wie mareike
schulz wirklich wird sich wohl die
meisten menschen wünschen dass sie nicht
für ihnen vermutlich gäbe die haie fleck
wert wie das ist also die vorstellung wo
viele vor ihr wählt die so lang ist wie
gott blieben aber dass das mögliche
spruch hörige voix parkett und bestelle
dinge zweite frau die ihren mann trägt
und dann mal was die frau betreut
louis
besser gut so stoff graphen her und ihr
mann louis sie ist 73 er 77 jahre alt
gerade im grünen schon hin und wieder
untersucht wenn die antworten bekommt
wäre vieles einfacher
das ist eben der evonik kommt die
diagnose alzheimer kam vor zwei jahren
gerade als sich louis linie von seinem
speiseröhrenkrebs und seine frau graca
von ihren brustkrebs erholt hatte mit
dem stift kosten bezeichnete farbe
führung probieren man richtig gut sein
und jetzt kommt es nämlich ist das so
wie sehr der abbruchs gebracht das ist
immer der spitze mitgemischt
womit sport eben so viel wie möglich
also wird das was auf die kranken durch
den ganzen mist und überhaupt der
wirklich nebensächlich und sagen jetzt
erst auspacken und die kann man ja
gesagt und ausparken
hätte schmid und der manfred 73 und 75
jahre aufnehmen so walter würfel gegen
alzheimer sind drei dritte plätze sind
in weimar dann hat sie dafür klappt aber
sie hat für depressionen
sie hätte schmidt hat alzheimer bei
ihrer mutter und ihre schwester
miterlebt
es ist traurig dass ich meine schon sind
sie da
das war's aber bestellt und ein anruf
aus sheens look trinken muss aber
rabatte winken
der stern weist einen tag pro woche
verbringt hätte schmidt in der tages und
nachtcreme akin einbruch zwei vormittage
trainiert sie in der memory klinik in
glattbrugg kleine zeit inseln für ihren
manfred braun berlin sondern
funktionieren hat sie mir kasemi
es ist einmal und dies für immer so viel
kurz wie möglich meint rund 40 jahren
kann man nicht einfach wegschieben
das ist etwas schuldig nein ich bin
nicht schuldig schon immer gemacht was
sie könne nicht einfach bis zum garten
führen
beziehungen sind es nach
wie gehen sie damit um dass sie nur um
gas sind erschienen nämlich media nutzt
sieht und der conny kompensieren mit ein
bisschen mehr wichtig ist cannabis
aber ich weiß wenn man könnte das weiß
ich muss so gründig copd sich anzukommen
eigentlich ist und was politisch oder
ohne uns christen überlegt genannte
funktion als hauptinitiator das ist ja
das problem
den bedenken natürlich die disa chrom
und dann kann sie ist immer gut und was
macht sie denn jetzt ruhig
julia war mitglied einer grossbank
grazia linie war für die beiden söhne da
weiß das was der züchter fixen größe
schwer die verrückt so nicht lange
bitten
abgeschmiert vorschau in zügen
so etwas ist nicht lustig das wiederum
kann nicht einkaufen aus
gedächtnistraining beim ehepaar schmid
heute abend übernimmt karin walz vom
entlastungsdienst schweiz ins theater
stellt das also ich bewundere sie wird
aus und dass sie dann doch immer nur die
fröhlichkeit hat und sie mochte mancher
witz mit dem louis weiß ich wirklich
bewundere sehr verehre tony machen aber
darum dass ich mit mir gesprochen der
mir denn zusammenzustellen
karin machte bereits nach mach's gut
die krankheit hat als handy und fredi
schmid ein eingespieltes team gemacht
habe ist frisch verliebt
ist das jetzt also grund dass sie jetzt
so sorgen vor einem bussi familie zeit
weitergedreht und so vieles vieles ich
liebe afrika ist studiendirektor
passieren ist dankbarkeit für das was
sie braucht hat zieht er über 116 euro
pro was sie haben
lukas wurden so der kreischef ist ziehen
die zu überleben
[Musik]
wer angehörige die pflege muss der bau
als ich selber denke will wenn die
pflegenden irgendwann raum für ihren
kräften wenn ich nehm rentieren angebot
wie diät tages und nach klinik dort
seien brach diese mithilfe zum genau das
verhindern
die tages und nacht klinik in embrach
ist spezialisiert auf die pflege von
dementen menschen angehörige können
demenzkranke hier zu ihrer entlastung
für temporäre aufenthalte unterbringen
für ferien- oder einzelne tage die tages
und nacht klinik bietet 16 temporäre
plätze und ist an 365 tagen geöffnet
[Musik]
die denken noch das was die frau linie
macht dass wir es nicht schaffen
ich hatte auch will smith als zenzi ohne
emotionen im spiel
bitteschön die sauna aber ich glaub der
idm rahmen hätten seit dem moment geben
sie bemerkte ein ganzes zimmer buchen
entlasten tagesklinik wein sind sie so
wie ich sie zum sage ich mir hilfe
juni größter der alzheimer den honig ist
jetzt besser wird jetzt muss ich morgen
hat sie dafür in macht oder immer für
sich
eigentlich ist das schon für mich klar
dass es für ihn stimmt etwas ganz
anderes gefühl hätten dass es vielen sie
durch ihre angehörigen quasi abschied
oder was immer schwerer fall zu uns als
ohne not bringen
wir leben ja ganze sprache formel uhr
genannte partnerschaften extrem brisant
und ich glaube nicht dass man
ursprünglich gemeint hat gibt so viel
dass man sich forschungs bietet und
aber das gefühl ich bete für mich ein
partner da sie und ich schwöre doch das
grüne leisten dass ich sehr stark und
schuldgefühl im sinnvoll ist brauche ich
hilfe doch nicht ohne menschen wie frau
lianne her oder der schnee drinnen
voraussehen wie das gesundheitssystem
zerbrechen
ja das kann man so sagen das größte
praktisch nicht
die schweizer sind ja okay das ist immer
noch so dass ich immer nur so und ich
glaube das ist gesellschaftlich längere
und immer nur wichtig ist dass man seine
hand ist das ganze linien deren magie
hat es bei x unterstützung
was denken sie wenn ist im moment das
ist eigentümer zumindest lege mir lagen
eigentlicher tag zu tag und wenn ich
krank werde wenn ich treffe mich nie
recht intensiver bedienen
da wird er wieder spontan nach situation
komplett wie ist das wenn er zum
beispiel in einer tagesklinik gott was
denken sie wie viel das ich darunter
damit über wohnen ist das kann ich nicht
100 prozentig sagte ich glaube so jetzt
weiß ich wie immer sprechen wie es läuft
nach wie vor unsicherheit nicht so recht
was passiert wie stark sie für siemens
ag hält dass er einfach dennoch holen
jupiter und peter kox werte spielen und
das älterwerden alt werden
da war es mir oh das ist nichts für
schwächlinge erfordert einige user ihr
leben ziehen also tony christie berühmte
schweizer malerin hat mir als wichtiges
buch nicht wissen wer ich bin
in ituri beck courage buch laschet fürs
alter und ich bin ich aufs wc für das
alter für familien als älter werde ich
glaube wirklich dass bruch mit neues
entdecken dass gott für mich immer alles
gleich aber anders aber ich nehme für
mich wo jetzt angestellt bin im
gesundheitswesen es mit kreativem
ausschnitte dieser villingen für das
brauchen heute einfach auf deine noten
muss strom hoch wie vor stark gemacht
hat also dass man darum wichtig sind und
für mich ist das ein total wertvolle
spruch wurde ein buch als buch los ich
glaube dass buchen jeder als
einzelpersonen und gesellschaft berlin
herr und frau schmitt die ein glücklich
und die heizung projekt werden aber wenn
ein mensch ist gleich heim muss dann ist
das auch wieder ein richtig großer
schritt und claudia knüpfen begleitet
sie auf dem weg und sie weiß aber sommer
moment beschäftigt was ihnen auf gott
claudia knöpfel ist beraterin von jutta
kehr der aufsuchenden individuellen
demenz aufklärung und beratung bei ihren
besuchen in den wohnungen von kranken
und deren angehörigen hörten geschichten
von menschen in höchste not anonym
erzählen uns zwei betroffene
stellvertretend für viele andere von
ihren sorgen und nöten
ich will am 1 somit dürfe jetzt würdig
haben auswärts schlagen gruppe nur das
wirklich schön und ich ja selber erkannt
und benannt
das problem hat nicht wahr dass das sind
jährige frau im hilft wenn sie im zeit
hat oder wenn sie mir irgendwer anfangs
eigentlich haben mit ihren kolleginnen
bedarfsgerecht und das ist auch ein
punkt sie dass diese kunden handy os
erscheinen die ich mir gemerkt oder irre
ich bin nur der vater erkannt und habe
da eine akute und seit ich keine chance
es gott nicht
brühl und neben mir hat auch nicht
christus machen macht doch für mich
macht doch für mich ich bin einfach mehr
als schlechte iv woche so wird mir
danach lockt das sind 2 und simon oder
beklagt sich und die anderen in lima hat
sehr verstört und zum die situation sei
nicht akzeptieren
zum sinn vater zu uns dann wirklich den
augen und sagen sie und in der ganzen
zeit wurden immer die heimat hat sie
eigentlich natürlich ist was sie sich
erhofft aber im ganzen ist dass er
wieder selber für sich zu machen und hat
das einfach nicht übers herz brachte sie
einfach kinder erkannt ich darf das
nicht will er das amt das ich kann die
tour damit dass ich relativ ungewöhnlich
worden bin dass wir persönlich fühle
[Applaus]
claudia knöpfel
offenbar ist eine müßige des pflegeheims
ganz viel gefühl verbunden
die geschichte um als gehörte ich statt
der regelfall oder endlose na ja ich
habe das wirklich sehr sehr häufig und
also trägt über tabs wissen versprechen
die halte das bis zum schluss für einen
tisch und stuhl dauer dass man
überfordert ist sich dass sie gestohlen
und ist heim
das ist für häufig ärzte also bis zu dem
moment als ein eigenes lang war haben
die könige meldet sich häufig erst wenn
es wirklich fast immer gott sie möchte
jetzt besser wissen und küsse umsätze
und damit aber immer der grenze und
damit auch ganz viele gut gemeinte tipps
über foren dumme war jj fx kühlen sie
wissen wie sie laufen und co
das sind typische glüht wo wenig wie
etwa bio kriterien ab gott selber gar
keine sicherheit dass er sich an
frisches benannt ist das so
wir bekommen mit einem unfall mit einem
anderen eigentümer darüber diskutieren
was für dich selber die beste option
und da ist also schwierigkeit dass sie
selber 30 cent je überhaupt das problem
sondern nur zum feld hätte das problem
und genau der ankündigung ermuntere das
wirklich mit über tempo räte mit dem
bestehenden dass ich den grünen dass die
den emotional weniger betroffen sind das
sachlich und bin und dass der wahre
schätze gemacht
es gibt einsatz wo viele jahre den
zeigen aber es weiß doch nicht immer so
gut was ihm oder ihre kultur das kränze
oder ihn an jemals gut wie nicht haben
doch nicht weg offen verstimmt ist
dagegen immer bestimmt sie sind experten
in bezug auf
sie können ihre frau am allerbesten oder
mutter oder der vater je nachdem und der
gefühlte integration sind flächen
betreuen wie da sie sind experte in
bezug auf
und da haben wir mit den mannschaften
sind ganz wichtige teil dass man sie mit
ins boot nimmt dass sie so etwas ist
richtig und was ist schwierig für die
person und pflegt in wirklichkeit von
den profis übernommen werden wenn der
schritt dänemark macht ist dass man
immer die highlight kommen immer zu
eindruck je nach dem sohn und den ist
grundschuld fühlt das ist jetzt erledigt
und erlebt wird und können sogar schule
gefühl aber ich kann jetzt wieder gut
schwimmen aber eigentlich ist so
hässlich dass mir jetzt freut es wieder
schwimmen oder sich freut mit der nacht
überschlafen
also doch mit dem schuldgefühl das netz
besser gott sie 14 stücke die und
zuschauen lernprozess dass sich wieder
dörfer freue dass leute mit denen blüten
auch gespräche mit etwas auch die mit
freude mit ihren gefühlen luftangriffe
claudia knüpfen und das liegt weiß ich
von anfang an schwer und mit dem
übertritt für die haie setzen und
vielleicht sein kommen aber dafür machen
nein richtig tour startet ein aufblühen
das sehen wir jetzt
[Musik]
da dieser die frau mit dem scooter eine
klärung nase fahrt fort und auch pelé
und der urlaubswelt russland sein vater
hat sie eine eigene quelle selber
bestimmen und er hat sich entschieden
zum voreilig auch mit exit aus dem leben
scheiden derart seres es lieber gehabt
wonach sich zu entscheiden
entscheidungen strafe dass die auch
nachts würde meine jacques i und das ist
natürlich nagen zurückgegangen dann im
alter vorher ist günstig sie war audi
ein oder andere watsch getan hat und er
auskühlt und so hat er das immer
formuliert er sie geht es also nicht nur
um sagt die schwäbin massen irgendwie
genug und jetzt sollen zu hören und
tatsächlich einem remix
naja hat eben dass ich sagte meine
man sieht nur gast an der neuen trasse
dort und so das ihs isuppli das bild auf
jeden fall hat er dann entschieden jetzt
sehr wichtig aber das ist eine politisch
morgens sieht das natürlich auch in
längeren entscheidungsprozesse muss man
wissen muss wie ein vater das ist
abgehakt hat ist mir relativ einfach
gewann
es ist seine entscheidung und die wird
morgen in die wohnung schließlich sie
war noch nicht mit
sterbehilfeorganisationen würde ich
sogar eine närrische offizier hat die
man nur waffe die hsg option obwohl nur
möglich ist hätte und wie wenig sie mir
viel hätten der entscheid wo ihrem vater
kam mögliche perspektive dass er zum
beispiel irgendeine strike over also das
hat schon große rolle gespielt der roxy
wo sich das kommen entscheidung
jeden schlagen können
die will ich nur sagen aber die zusage
dass ich führe ihn ganze schwere
buchstäblich sie wenn sie das ist okay
sagte sie ich bin so wie ich habe mir
damit wächst aber zu schwierigkeiten
kommt erklingt die hand dass mehr
kapiert klostergut ist eben viele
sportler froh darüber denn wir zahlen
das ist der maus erlebte gibt und so
schauen so gut dann für mich hat das
billigt und was mich belastet sind damit
und da habe ich bei grunde punkt ein
dann sind sie nicht genau warum es ist
unter druck wodurch neben ehrungen so
und so und aber antwortete wohl auswahl
der stücke winters nicht ab das kommt
einfach nicht was ich einfach platt mit
dem land prozessen teilten man muss
nicht erst anfangen über die toten und
über sterberate sondern dass er das so
betitelte zu
dabei geht es hier das rät studiere
jetzt nur mehr etwa gehörige vielleicht
ein teil der wunsch ein schnee- oder man
könne darüber reden und bücher bremens
sterben ergebnisse bestätigt
also wenn das ihr debüt bestellt und
eben auch oder sondern richtige also zum
beispiel dass meine eltern als referent
wo willst du hin wenn ihre werkstatt des
alters ein richtiger oder richtig gut
für das probieren da aber das passiert
natürlich allianz stellen dem er denkt
man will ja nicht dass den quasi mutter
oder der vater das gefühlskino gattungen
abschiede arbeitsmarkt dass er seine
diplomatischen bringen es ist wenig aber
nicht dass der druck ja dass wir mit der
familie red was passiert wenn ich bin
grimm trat wenig emotion viertelstunde
sturz alles futsch und das beste
was denken sie was ist wichtigste zum
guten liga sowie das zeigt das ist
wunderbar dass man irgendwie haben wir
mal wie du nix ist nur noch ein foto und
ich danke dir die biografie von dateien
ist es mehr möglich besonderer wenn sie
mich fragen was will ich dann würde ich
habe gern mit dem gefühl alt werden
es ist kurz es ist eine fixe sachen
erlebt und ich mir gewünscht haben
erfüllen
und ich würde aber er hoffe dass ich
nicht so schmerzen haben dass ich
einfach jeden tag dank herrgott
wenigsten tag vorbei man kann ja egal
altwerden ist nichts für feiglinge und
schönsten ist und was nicht machst du
weißt du wie es kommt nicht weil ich
jetzt besser und das gemacht und hätte
sie es verpasst haben sie es ja viel
verpasst
land rover und ich war stolz wie das
ruft das alle briefe gebucht und so dass
ich irgendwie zurück und für mich was
sie tun besser und er holt man gewinnt
und das sind dann bin ich mutter
ich hoffe sich die zuversicht und der
punkt wo sie haben noch ganz lange denn
nur so viel das ist dass die reporter
spezial das ganze leben vor der ersten
stunde vom labour vor der geburt bisher
genau zu der
letzten stunden dankbar sind alle folge
findet sie jetzt auch online wenn sie
den ganzen schönen angemessen
[Musik]